everyone even the biggest names in
esports are capable of committing
blunders but only a select few will
spend all of eternity
getting ragged on for it whether it's an
uncanny ability to get trapped atop
cliffs frying to death in a sea of
fabled self-administered flames or a
catastrophic instance of bad real-time
mathematics there are no shortage of
memes surrounding esports's most
hilarious and heartbreaking mishaps here
comes the tension here comes the push
down on white stairs waiting for the
vault on in is canadian will he be able
to secure the kill he sees the tracers
go no scyther will win the fight but in
the ever-evolving esport that is
valorant there is one signature screw-up
that soars above
and well away from
the rest
how does he hit that mid-air i'm mid-air
i'm midair
you can't make this up
no
no no no
it doesn't work today we're pouring one
out for yaseen subrosa taufek the
notoriously cracked csgo turned valorant
competitor whose infamous rocket mishaps
have canonized him as the patron saint
of really
really bad razors
oh yeah
of course i get flash when i oh dude
it's cursed
it's cursed it's cursed it's cursed it's
cursed someone did some voodoo
the thing is sabrosa is no stranger to
scrutiny regarding his aim and let me
tell you it uh hasn't always been
playful
so who is subrosa really why did
everyone accuse him of cheating in cs go
you know i thought like the pros were
smart enough to be like oh he doesn't
cheat look at him like he's doing this
and he's doing that but if it wasn't the
case and how is it that his inability to
land a show-stopper has given birth to
one of valeran's oldest and most
oft-memed terms of art
no rose no rose please
don't panic don't panic
that's a new one i don't even think we
can call that one roso
okay so before we blast pack our way
into sabrosa's story i gotta do the
thing where i ask you to like subscribe
and turn on the notifications
i was gonna segue into a clip of me
being rosalted or something but uh
i'll be honest your boy is
way too clean with it to even let him
get the alt off in the first place
before she even got it off
now unsurprisingly like a lot of
valorent's earliest aimbots this
french-canadian fragger of moroccan
descent hailed from the skill-intensive
shores of cs go what you may not know is
that he was grinding free-to-play
shooters for years before that i was
playing aba i was like 13 years old 14
years old 15 years old and i was just
like just playing for fun you know like
with my irl friends and some friends i
met online and then eventually there's
like these little tournaments they would
do but they were so little it was like
for 500 sometimes like for in-game items
you know i was like sign up for them and
i thought i thought it was pretty fun
and then some of the people that would
compete in those games or those
tournaments would always like talk about
cs and i was like let me just try the cs
thing everyone like kept talking about
so i downloaded cs and i fell in love
with it and everything was just better
by the end of 2015 subrosa was starting
to dip his toe into actual competitive
play and by 2016 was cutting his teeth
in small north american leagues lands
and qualifiers crossing towards elbow
both his teammates coming through ct
uber just coming through heaven cleaning
up one two members of the next year and
andrew continues with sabrosa fights one
and two and now it's a one beat
one
and subrosa just came huge for nixon cs
when i first touched a computer because
obviously when i was a kid like i wanted
to be a soccer pro whatever like i
wanted to support sports sports and then
when you don't make it like at a certain
age like 11 12 years old 13 years old in
quebec it's kind of like pointless
you're kind of just wasting your time so
as soon as i kind of like committed to
playing on the computer like playing
those games like soldier friend ava i
was putting like
ridiculous amount of time like it was
like if i'm not in school or i'm not
doing anything like i would be on the
computer and then playing those like
eight years before playing cs like did i
i started playing cs i think at like 16
17 and i played like fps free to play
for like
10 years old 11 years old i think we
started like the first one soldier front
or soldier front two so seven years just
playing straight fps and when i switched
this yes it's like similar game it's
pretty much the same thing i just had to
learn the mechanics so like literally a
year of playing all day every day took
me to pro level come the end of the
summer he'd gotten his first big break
on counter logic gaming and was
regularly seen facing off against the
biggest baddest bruisers nacs had to
offer nothing's traded off but it seems
like the damage has been done a little
bit another kill almost through the
smoke some rosa entering the site shroud
is massively exposed so roses just has a
sick game sense right they're almost
hitting that shot like five times in the
smoke kit on schedule so there's a
chance here for cloud9 still automatic
he's been good for this team so far they
because they have the kit they can let
that smoke expire but subrosa with a
very nice peak comes out on top of it
and then right through the box and it
was right around then that a narrative
that had been burgeoning for some time
really began to capture the attention of
the community
namely
that rosa was
well
sus you see earlier that year a certain
clip from one of sabrosa's league
matches began making the rounds on
various counter-strike forums and if you
were around back then and are familiar
with the details of rosa's notoriety
you know exactly which clip i'm talking
about i remember i was on teamspeak we
had just played this match uh with
edixia and we like you know every pro
player like after they're done with
their match they watch the vaude and
like their own clips and like oh look at
this 2k i had so i was doing that on my
own on teamspeak and i was watching the
vod and then i saw the like vent thing
and i was like wait guys look at this
look at this and i clipped it and i sent
it to them and then as soon as i sent it
to them they sent it to more people and
they're like yo look at what sarosa just
did that's when i was like okay maybe i
should have done that and then i went to
the forum on yesterday and i would like
[ __ ] post sometimes like just troll
around and then as soon as i posted that
clip that night that's when like i
started feeling it like almost instantly
like almost messages everywhere like yo
what what was that like what was that
like i don't know i thought it was
pretty funny like yeah look at this like
i just did it randomly and it happened
to be like on him that day would
probably the the day i was like oh [ __ ]
okay people actually think i cheat he
broke the vent
why would he look there
well what would be the point to look
there
if if he broke the vent
there there'd be no point to look
through the wall there okay what is that
accomplishing what is looking through
the wall accomplishing you already heard
that the vents broken what he's probably
doing is he hears the vent break and
he's checking with his cheats to see if
the guy's been boosted fueled by the
desire to unearth even more
incriminating evidence people started
scrutinizing sabrosa's clips like never
before eventually spectators started to
take notice of the fact that rosa's aim
was admittedly
kind of weird a quick study of his pov
revealed frantic seemingly prescient
flicks that often resulted in his
crosshair flying the way of an enemy
player model through a wall
on land when i first started playing cs
and like just fps game in general and
like people watched and like all that i
was always like you said the low sense
kind of guy and i use my arm a lot of
people will use wrist for the micro
micro movement but for me was always arm
arm arm arm arm and it was the thing
where like i wanted to always impress
people so i was like flick everywhere so
when i first went to cs tournaments and
cs4 and cs teams i would have that aims
of like yo look at my aim like i'm
flicking everywhere and it's like
working and i say wow sometimes i'll hit
the crazy shot and sometimes i'll always
like whiff play like sub rosa for a
second
this is my
best
subreza
impression
and then uh when we went to that
northern arena i remember i was like
warming up on aimbots and like i
remember like people watching me and
like being like what the [ __ ] like how
does he do that how does he do that and
[ __ ] like that sounds like thinking like
yeah it's like working like yeah look at
my flakes kind of thing but it was not
consistent like looking back at it now
that i have more experience and i'm like
a little smarter in the game the aim
style is definitely not consistent like
it's bad to just flick around everywhere
like a like a 16 years old kid that's
just trying to hit heads it's really bad
like obviously relying on cross
replacement is going to be more
consistent now as much as we all
love counter-strike there's
no denying the fact that it has
something of a fraught and indeed ugly
history
when it comes to cheating from the wild
west that was 1.6 to the infamous
vacconing in the early days of global
offensive a hysteria surrounding sketchy
clips has encircled the franchise for
much of its existence and
found himself in the eye of that very
storm
you don't hike in matches you don't hack
in right now don't they look the same
downloaded hats
to see how hacks work so he could try to
mimic it himself but i don't know how
long ago he did this
like i don't know if you did this like
what is it
listen
i'm not going to lie dude like it's
super easy for you really odd real soft
but you look super
ruby shady right now with the way you're
trying to play it off things went from
bad to worse when sabrosa's skeptics
discovered he had an account on a
website notorious for offering hacks but
sabrosa maintains that it was a false
smoking gun so when i used to play ava
there's a website called mpgh and it was
it what okay i said the thing is it
wasn't only the hacking stuff like blah
blah blah oh i go there i download
cheese first of all if you go on a
website like this and you download
cheese i probably guarantee you get bad
in a day like you you can go ahead and
try that like doesn't matter but if you
look at the profile of the account you
could see like zero downloads you could
literally see i have not like as soon as
you download something on the website
it'll show on your profile like one
download two download three download you
could literally see on the website that
i had zero download and also you could
see one forum post that's those are the
two things you can see in the website if
you go in the forum post which people
did was a big threat of me selling my av
account with all the skins but the most
incriminating part of all of this and
what the reddit detectives somehow
missed
was his name in latin sub rosa literally
translates to under the rose but in the
language's post 1500 revival which is
often called new latin it was coined as
an idiom to denote
secrecy since roses have been associated
with themes of concealment and silence
since the days of antiquity sub space
rosa it means like something in latin or
whatever
okay
something done in secret
something done in secret yeah oh so
you're hacking now to be fair
not
everyone thought he cheated
and they said as much
if he loses this like
i don't know what to say he cheats
and if he loses then that's really sad
i'm just playing guys he doesn't cheat
do i think subrose is cheating no
no
so rosa is not cheating get over it
all right
in all seriousness
all the witch hunting in cs go is just
so terrible unfortunately it wasn't
enough to thwart the harassment he was
receiving in virtually every nook and
cranny of counter-strike at one point
the level of heat subrosa was attracting
even forced his own org clg to ask some
uncomfortable questions like i had this
meeting with like the ceo at the time
and like the vp or something like that
they were like yo like do you actually
cheat like you know what i mean and i'm
like in my head i'm like yeah i'm just
trolling i'm just like i'm really just
showing people online i'm like are they
serious like do they actually think i
cheat because i'm in a gaming house
playing in front of them i just came
back from a land like in my head i'm
like i'm pr i proved my team i can play
like i did good at the land in my head
when it started getting annoying it was
like oh man like if the pro scene thinks
that like it might be my like my career
you know i thought like
the pros were smart enough to be like oh
he doesn't cheat look at him like he's
doing this and he's doing that but
if it wasn't the case yeah i just feel
like your career is kind of ruined for
no reason you know what i mean like it
just feels like let's say something
happens where like clg cuts me or clg
bench me or clg like happens to like i
want to leave like it felt like maybe i
couldn't get that other chance because
like other teams think this or other
teams think that and then the other
thing is like social is a big thing in
esports you know like having a good
brand is like important and just
messaging the orgs and talking to orgs
and them knowing my reputation it felt
like a lot of them would like fade away
from it just because of the cheating
allegation and i would just be like
sitting at home like bro we're doing
good as a team we deserve an
organization we could be going pro with
this lineup with the little support we
could get but it just felt like orgs
didn't want to like link with that it's
just like no and then that's when it
really got annoying i was like wow
that's got like that's
after parting ways with clg for personal
reasons at the start of 2017 subrosa
took a short break from professional
play before re-entering the tier 2 scene
with an unsigned team who briefly became
district 7. he then joined ghost gaming
with whom he was able to start grazing
the upper echelon of competition but
never getting the better of it it's
balls and fallen to try and close this
out for sk so broser and mordell to look
to hold on the bomb goes down flash
comes through and it's perfect boltz
finds the first it is just wardell back
against the wall and bolt's gonna double
down
that's sk closing this out in a swift
2-0 16 to four here on dust two their
map pick sabrosa would go on to serve
brief stints with the likes of united
lazarus and even cloud9 before spending
2020 as a still unsigned up-and-comer
whose next real opportunity might never
come and then as with a lot of north
american hopefuls at that time
fate extended a hand in the form of
valorent we were at flashpoint in la
with wardell and fns we had this team
called orglas and we were doing pretty
well honestly and we could not find a
sponsor but then we like we heard about
this game coming out in a week and then
me and wardell would like i would always
tell wardell i'd be like man i'm telling
you this game is going to be big we
should probably switch this game is
going to be big and then me and i like
when i convinced wardell to like
actually give it a full try with me when
it when it came out
me and him would come up to like fns
like a random time like we'd be outside
just taking a walk be like yo john just
put on just come with us just come with
us like we're quitting we're quitting
that's it we're out and then he would
always think we're trolling and then
eventually the game did come out we
played it and we actually did quits like
we actually fell in love with the game
we thought it was cool and we committed
to it almost instantly rosa and his
compatriots were scooped up by team
solomid and thanks to their youth
creativity and penchant for trying new
things they were quick to cement
themselves as some of the game's
earliest most innovative juggernauts
oh
this is gonna be huge
he's gonna spawn all of them right now
one two three four oh my god looking for
the ace right now and it's about to be
peaked out here
silva arrow to come out and he's going
to win this fight and he does with
another headshot there's the old as well
that's going to reveal all the positions
here of these remaining tsm players also
broser he looks absolutely on for this
one pushing for oh no
but they'll be back in here they can
heal they will be fine but it's a 2v3
now it's going to be a 1v1 it's just up
to sick he has been spectacular but it's
not gonna matter because wardell gets
the final shot and t
s m are your phase
valorent invitational champions
ironically it didn't take long for the
community to start harassing sabrosa
over his aim
just
not for the reasons you might think we
were in scrims with tsm and uh i wanted
to pick up the duelist role i think it
was drone playing the second duelist but
i wanted to try to do this role and then
jordan was going to go and breach and
then we were like sitting there like yo
what does you want to play like i'm like
yeah i can play phoenix i can play this
i can play that i can't even play race
and then my team was like raised like i
i've never played race before like
they've seen my phoenix they've seen my
dis they've seen like that but never the
the rays and then i remember that they
instagram like i locked and raised like
yeah let's give it a try i'll play raise
today and i did really good
like insanely good like offered like
just not with the alt not with the old
just with like ever like in general so i
did really good in those screams and
they were like okay yeah yeah let's have
you play raise
and we played the f i think it was a
first strike uh invitational and we made
it really far like i was owning and then
when we made playoffs like there's three
or four be3s in a row i could not catch
a break with the old there's some that
was like really bad why would you out
there blah blah i died whatever go next
there was some that was like this guy is
blind stunned and i'm like that's a good
old but then he would like kill me full
blind or his teammate would flash me or
like my teammate would block me or like
i was always something that would happen
so just not getting a kill with it and
that there was three b with reason or
everyone was like yeah it's a rose at
all and from this unfortunate string of
calamitous showstoppers the now infamous
roosevelt was born
the thing that pushed me even harder is
i was like i would stream daily
and i would like for the next like two
weeks after that meme was created
everyone would be my chat just ready to
type it just like yo let's let's you
play raise i'm ready to type it i would
play raz just to entertain them and the
earth would never hit at some point i
was like
it's whatever within no time rosa's
rowdy rambunctious misfires had become
one of the single most memeed upon
things in valorant and with good reason
homie was cursed every time this mother
pulled out his show-stopper
you knew what was going to happen next
it's just i'm curious man
it's what i've been saying it's what
i've been it's what i'm saying i'm
cursed i've been saying this for years
man it didn't matter who you were where
you were playing or what alt you were
with if you maxed up those charges and
didn't convert twitch chat was spamming
one thing and one thing only
ah don't say it don't say it please
please please chat don't say it i got
two kills don't say it man please don't
say it guys it didn't even count i
didn't even pull out the first stage of
the rocket there's four stages i have to
get through to shoot the rocket i didn't
even get past the first one if i got
past the first stage then sure but i
didn't even pull it out yet man
it's not even a rose old man
hey after the rosa old meme like two or
three weeks after i figured out how to
own it was fine it was fine when i
figured i had it all but it was like too
late the the fire was like
it's too big too big
all right i don't give a [ __ ] i actually
don't care i actually don't care but
contrary to what you might expect being
the butt end of one of valeran's oldest
and most seminal jokes
hasn't irked rosa in the slightest in
fact oddly enough
he's actually really thankful for it
like i'm super grateful man i have a
great community like just they keeping
me grinding you know because like look i
look forward to streaming i think it's
super fun since switching to valorant
rosa has built up a following of loyal
adoring fans who show up every day to
goad him cheer him on and show him a
boatload of love his viewers may have
shown up for the whiffs but he's given
them plenty of other reasons to stick
around
i wish they would have holds already
what is happening
wait what
boy i am dead ass she fell asleep wait
[Music]
going up
oh
[Music]
for the first time in his career rosa
can truly be said to have earned the
respect and admiration of not only his
peers but the esports community at large
and short it may be true that after all
these years people still give him [ __ ]
about his aim
but
at least it's for the right reasons not
out of malice but more importantly
for the memes
and i always laugh at people like where
are the people that used to think i
cheat now but they would never like pop
up you know everyone's like you know i
never i always knew i always knew i was
new now they're all fans for i swear i
would hit every raise old if instead of
saying here comes the party with that
like cringe voice it says baby welcome
to the party you know what i mean like
they put a pop smoke [ __ ] in that [ __ ]
i swear to god i would never miss that
[ __ ]
absolutely dude i'm getting good man i'm
getting real fast
i speed around that [ __ ] dude i'm
getting fast
yeah
i could have done this
dead ass i do i can do a don't at me now
and like
11 minutes deadass